what was the last text just i love you
so much and i can't wait to see you
tomorrow bob saget's wife kelly rizzo
gets emotional recalling their last
conversation
he was just on his way home or back to
his hotel and just was telling me what a
wonderful show he had and how it was so
amazing and he was
happy and just loving what he did
it made him so happy
to just bring laughter to people the
late comedian's wife sits down with good
morning america and opens up about her
husband who was found unresponsive in a
hotel room in orlando florida and
pronounced dead on january 9. just hours
after he finished a stand-up show
outside of jacksonville he was 65 years
old he just wanted to spread love and
laughter and
he did it so amazingly and i'm just so
proud of him
because
he truly brought people together you
know that's one of the reasons i'm
really happy so to be able to just
entertain and
make people laugh and do something just
for the sheer joy he had
the
biggest heart of anyone i've ever known
she put
everybody
first if you had a problem
he was the first person that was going
to take care of it and help you and he
was just
the most caring
and kind and
thoughtful person in the wake of bob's
death the 42 year old says she's been
moved by the love and support she's
received from his full house co-stars
every single one of them has been so
kind and supportive
and they've been there every step of the
way and they've just
assured me that they'll be there for me
and
i know that would make bob very happy
it's emotional we love each other and
we've been friends all these years
and we've been there for each other it's
just it makes me so happy a memorial
service was held for bob in los angeles
last friday and of course the full house
cast was there including john stamos
dave coulier mary kate and ashley olson
laurie lachlan and candace cameron beret
among others
it's an extended family we've always
loved each other and that's what i think
made the show a success is it was in
between the lines that stuff that
happens
when it's real between people in a
separate interview with hoda koppy on
the today show kelly reveals that she
spoke at the service as painful as it
was was
beautiful to be surrounded by so many
people who loved him and who loved each
other i can't even verbalize the level
of support the food and travel blogger
also tells a touching story about the
kind of guy bob was proving just how
special their marriage was
when he was away he would go to bed at
two and then wake up at four so he could
be on the six a.m flight we valued every
single second that we had together there
was nothing you know left unsaid and
nothing left on the table so those are
the things that i'm just trying to
hold onto
[Music]